this is Startalk the end is coming it's
this year end is near and is very near
and there are some really crazy plans of
how this mission is going to end and it
involves essentially crashing this
orbiter that's doing all this amazing
science through these very expensive
instruments on board crashing this thing
into the comment ok now that sounds
matte very much like when I was a kid I
would build a giant Lego castle and then
kick it down why why why is that the end
of the mission what is going on with you
guys I'm like you know I've always
wanted to break stuff so the problem we
have is the comet is moving away through
capillary and motion is moving away from
the Sun now the spacecraft is orbiting
around them or is in the same orbit
that's moving away from the Sun as well
losing the capability of generating
power so we'll get to a situation where
we would have to put it into hibernation
you had to do that before because they
move so far away from the Sun anyway and
because of the orbit the space problem
is now in with the comment it would
freeze we're also running out of fuel
we'll have no fuel left stone and the
best thing to do was to end the mission
in around September or October time
actually the reason for that is we get
to a time where the solar energy is
reducing but also we go into a
conjunction with the Sun so the signal
that we're getting from the spacecraft
is very minimal in that time period so
we kind of thought the end of September
would be a good time to close the
mission off now we could have just
switched the mission off or do something
more extravagant at the more extravagant
thing has been to control carry out
controlled impact with a comet I
controlled him I'm not a crash you know
that's what I tried to tell my insurance
company about my last controlled impact
I love this idea because it means on the
way down the instruments are still gonna
be on and they're gonna get tons of
information as they go down because this
will be the closest we've ever been with
the orbiter obviously that mean not
crashed it into the comet yet they've
done some amazing maths to work out
sorry math alright I'm in the States no
I forget men yeah we've done some some
very clever math to work out how to
orbit around this thing because it's not
quite it's haven't really got enough
gravity for an orbiter to just all be
it's not going to be in a gravitational
tractor pull but it's been empowered
flight a lot of the time so it's like do
what I don't get too close but this
comet is also active so it's got the
material streaming off the surface so
you don't wanna get our orbiter too
close and be hit by particles coming hey
this is like our best chance to get
close get some really detailed images of
the surface I think you know one pixel
is that gonna be a meter or better than
that do we hate with much I think once
we get within 10 kilometers we get we go
suck a meter 50 centimeters 10
centimeters we're gonna get very high
resolution images once we get down to
that level really and and so as you take
this as you capture these images and
you're still in orbit around the comet
as it's doing its controlled impact are
you going to be surveying all parts of
the comet like kind of going around it
and taking pictures like you know like a
radial camera like is that is will that
be the is that the case that for what
we're calling the last words of Rosetta
is actually still being destroyed so I
discuss is being calculated because
although that this comet is very low
density and has a weak gravitational
attraction it still has gravity so the
orbiter actually is now in about door
bit we're about 26 by 20 kilometer orbit
we will go closer and closer and closer
so we'll get below 10 kilometers and
once we get it below 10 kilometers
things get very complicated because of
this duck like bad like structure and so
we have a very weird gravitational
potential once we get down to that so
we'll have to put it
special orbit and really be careful at
how we control the spacecraft around
that time and we will feel perturbations
of that gravity and we will be
continuing to try and do as many
measurements as possible once we get
close by
now that was final words as we you know
we're talking about the last day of rows
out of what we do there is still being
discussed still being fine-tuned
we believe it will be some kind of
arresting maneuver from a Paris air
close Paris enter orbit so they'll have
like a maybe a an elliptic orbit that
goes within about 1 1 kilometer maybe
the surface maybe even lower depending
again on what we're doing in September
and then we'll inject towards the
comment and just set ourselves up to be
able to take that as close as possible
now the priority will be the imager but
also the mass spectrometer to sniff
everything as close as possible will
we'll have other instruments operating
but when we start getting too low power
during that period we really have to say
why these are the priority instruments
getting those images again the
high-resolution images are also our
resolution spectra from this there is
there any anticipation as to what the
comment will smell like because I'm
hoping Jasmine it's like a kind of a
Friday night in a bar area or in any
city in the US or the Britain or
wherever is telling me this comet will
smell like a drunken fart yeah pretty
recently yeah no good place to be it
smells like Jersey this is Startalk
you